pakistan's new prime minister is
promising to fix its economy and rebuild
ties with allies mps elected shaba
sharif after imran khan lost a
no-confidence vote but can he overcome
better political divisions and address
domestic and foreign policy challenges
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fuli batibo shabazz sharif has been
sworn in as pakistan's new prime
minister the former opposition leader is
succeeding imran khan who was removed
from office in a no-confidence vote
sharif will now form a temporary
government until a general election can
be held sometime next year while he
settles into his new office tens of
thousands of imran khan supporters are
protesting against his removal and more
than a hundred mps from khan's party
have also resigned in protest we'll get
to our discussion in just a moment but
first this report from kamal haider in
islamabad
after several weeks of uncertainty and
what was looking like a political
thriller pakistan now has a new prime
minister the 23rd prime minister mr
shabbat sharif was sworn in on monday
evening it is important to note that
pakistan terry can stop the outgoing
party decided to resign and mosque from
that parliament saying that shabbat
sharif had serious corruption charges
against him and that this was
unacceptable and that they will not
continue in a parliament that they
considered to be an imported government
imran khan had already appealed to his
people to come out on sunday night
across the country tens of thousands of
people came out and what is seen as an
endorsement of imran khan's stance that
there was a foreign conspiracy to bring
down his government through a vote of no
confidence imran would be wanting early
elections but the new party that is in
power and of course this is an
assortment and
an alliance of nine political parties
that have been able to unite on a single
agenda to oust imran khan will be
wanting to hold electoral reforms
something that imran khan's party did
not agree with the next few weeks and
months will be critical the pakistan
territory himself wants an early
election but it seems that this new
government in islamabad may not be ready
for that this is kamal haider for
inside story from
well
islamabad
incoming administration will need to
navigate multiple domestic and foreign
challenges inflation is more than 12
percent and pakistan's foreign debt is
at 130 billion dollars that's 43 percent
of its gdp
attacks by armed groups have been on the
rise in talks between the government and
pakistani taliban have failed and it
will need to improve relations with the
west which were recently damaged when
khan accused washington of conspiring to
topple him there's also the kashmir
dispute with india security in
afghanistan and the government will need
to oversee growing chinese investment
well let's hear what some pakistanis had
to say about their new leader and the
economy
people do not care whose government it
is whether it's pti people's party or
muslim league all they want is progress
in this country the main issue is that
inflation should be brought down so that
the poor man can survive the middle
class is the one that suffers most the
white collar person gets hit most by
inflation because he has to manage
things in such a way that he can
maintain and keep up appearances so
whoever comes into power they should be
able to control prices industries should
thrive there should be overall progress
we have hopes from shabazz sharif he's a
good leader and we hope that he'll
control prices and god willing he'll be
a good leader for the poor masses and
the country will progress
let's now bring in our guests all of
whom are joining us from pakistan's
capital islamabad zulfiqar bukhari was a
special assistant to former prime
minister imran khan maria iqbal tarana
is the general secretary of the human
rights wing of pakistan's people's party
and zubair iqbal is a political analyst
and pro-rector at the national
university of modern languages thank you
all for being with us on inside story
maria let me start with you can prime
minister shabaz sharif govern pakistan
effectively when there is so much
widespread support from for imran khan
from millions of pakistani especially
young pakistanis those who say he
doesn't have the mandate to govern what
do you say
when you talk about the support then you
know always this thing comes into my
mind we are living in a dot-com era and
we must not forget how easy it is to
manipulate the young minds because
pakistan's total population 66
population is of youth and today youth
has not been engaged with you or either
uh me or anybody else they are being
engaged with the phones so it's very uh
easy for uh anyone to manipulate or you
know to
install their own agendas through this
um social media and uh what we believe
in this time actually what has happened
when pti
came into the government 2018
after that i think it's been almost four
years they used all the government
resources
um to
manipulate to hijack young
prince of pakistan to
you know to install their own agendas
and this is what we see today because
young people are just not being ready to
understand the constitution of pakistan
and what is important of pakistan is a
democracy and whatever has happened in
last few days nothing has happened on
constitutional or undemocratic uh of
course no confidence vote or you know i
come from a party pakistan people's
party and everybody knows when pakis
pakistan was only
20 years old then pakistan people's
party came into being and
when pakistan was 25 years old
so five years old pakistan people's
party gave pakistan a complete
constitution okay which is our
responsibility as a young people to lead
to implement and to stand by it okay
let's allow zulfikar bukhari to respond
zulfikar maria says the millions of
people who've come out the young people
who've come out in support of imran khan
are being manipulated what do you
respond
i i think what my
my colleague is trying to say is that
pakistan's people's party and
pml noon
in the government in in charge at the
moment doesn't have any support from the
youth or the masses i think her entire
synopsis of what she's trying to build
up is basically saying that nobody has
come out for them the youth is not
behind them and the public mandate is
still with uh ex-prime minister imran
khan
she talks about pakistan's people's
party doing so much
their chairman who is from sin the
province of sin is still and if you look
at his personal constituency it's still
probably one of the most backward
constituencies in the entire country
um and their grandfather
father mother himself have been ruling
for decades and yet haven't been able to
give any progress to their own personal
constituency let alone the country i
think i think you rightly hit the nail
on the head when you started with that
he may have got the no vote confidence
in the in the national assembly uh by
making everyone against one man imran
khan however do they have the moral
authority do they have the public's
mandate if they do
then the simple question is why wouldn't
any prime minister who has come in now
shabbat sharif has been sworn in as
prime minister there's no one on the
road rejoicing there's nobody on the
streets celebrating so why wouldn't the
prime minister
which prime minister with any moral
authority would not want to go to
elections immediately right and sure let
me ask you and his own countrymen but
why did the opposition walk out then if
if you know if the opposition wants to
keep this government and this prime
minister honest why not participate in
the political process why walk out of
parliament
i'll explain to you i'll explain to you
why
we believe
we are fully aware of that we have been
in government let me put it like this
we've been in government for three and a
half to four years
when the commodity index prices
inflation was through the roof worldwide
it was a sky high
yet
the the pdm movement could not gather
themselves to remove and topple our
government what has happened in the last
30 to 60 days where this i wouldn't even
call it a super glue but this magical
glue has gel them all together to top of
the government when the when the
government is when the government's
ex-government's narrative is sky high
what might what magic glue or what magic
conspiracy came in that got them all
together and topple topple it when they
weren't even at their lowest when we
when our government was was at its
lowest in terms of opinion polls or
public polls they still couldn't manage
to do it why we're not lost last bit why
we're not participating and resigned
from the assembly is simply because we
feel it's an illegitimate government and
us sitting in the assemblies with what
we feel a foreign intervention will
legitimize this legitimate government
you haven't proved that there was
foreign intervention you you talk about
this foreign intervention accusing the
u.s and so on but that hasn't been
proven i'll come back to that in just a
few minutes but i do want to bring in uh
mr zubair iqbal into the conversation
and maria i'll allow you to respond uh
to what we've just heard uh from your
colleague uh mr uh iqbal i mean imran
khan as we've seen fairly uh commends a
fairly large audience especially among
young people we've seen millions take to
the streets in recent days and even
among members of the military the young
members of the military does it matter
what he does next if these massive
protests continue
are we likely to see the military step
in as it has in the past
well uh military has its own
constitutional role to play and they
have made it very loud and clear that
they are not interfering into the
political process if i can correctly
recall the statement given by the dg
isbr a few days ago when he was asked
point blank but this is not a matter of
military getting into things or getting
into the fray of the thing this is a
matter of the constitutional process
there has been some allegations leveled
by the pakistan territory and staff and
uh
the the the new prime minister
uh uh mr shabazz sharif has just pointed
out in his first speech that we are
going to make a commission parliamentary
security commission and where everything
will be investigated and he was uh bold
enough to say that even if an iota of
indication is coming towards us that we
have played into the foreign hand then
uh he said that he was ready to resign
at that point in time we must all
understand that this was the democratic
process and if you count the number of
votes it was the allied parties which
was previously with the pti and now they
have joined hands with
the opposition parties namely pmln and
pakistan people's party so it is it is
only those parties the uh the so-called
members of the pakistan tariq and staff
who were not
considering their policies in the
correct way they have not voted in this
uh
in this vote of no confidence so it's a
democratic process uh and uh prime
minister uh shabbat sharif has uh said
that we are not going to go against any
uh
any vendetta or or or making against
going against anybody so if if imran
khan and his party considers that they
should come out from the street it is
their democratic right if there is if it
is within the right of the political
domains if it is under the law of the
land they must gather they must raise
their voice and if they are able to
muster that much support and destabilize
the government and then push them into
the new elections so be it but for the
moment we must all accept the democratic
process and the law of the land all
right so we must accept the democratic
process you say maria let's talk about
the first big challenge for this
new prime minister and this new
government and that is the economy the
imf program has been suspended the
country is facing enormous deficit on
the fiscal side how will he steer the
country uh prime minister sharif
will the economy take a different
direction
from uh under imam khan yeah that's
where i wanted to reply because my
fellow colleagues said it's a time for a
celebration so why nobody is supporting
straba street at the moment because um
my dear everyone celebration time is
over nobody is dancing on the roads
anymore and anywhere
so you know the charismatic handsome
prime minister and all that this is very
outdated uh terms which our opponents
has been using because it's about the
life of a 220 million people because
it's not a theater or a movie or we are
not seeking for any drama in this
country we have to be very serious about
you know how we can
move forward and and let's try and move
forward the conversation then policy
crisis yeah
let's try and move forward the
conversation now because you will
disagree with uh zulfiqar on this how do
we address the biggest challenge right
now which is uh the economy how does he
uh the new prime minister go about doing
that yes of course the new prime
minister has his own policies of course
today yesterday he has taken oath now
the parliamentary commissions will be
formed for the economy and i'm sure that
will be uh in favor of pakistan because
he previously was being serving as a cm
of punjab and punjab is a where the half
of the population of pakistan has been
residing in is the biggest province and
uh economically
punjab has contributed a lot in the
pakistan's economy as well so i'm sure
they have their own policies which we
will see in the coming days
now at the moment we think in not only
economically but foreign policy is also
being a disaster so whatever the
disaster the previous government has
left i think it's the biggest challenge
for uh
the people who has just taken oath
yesterday and is the biggest challenge
for pakistan people's party pmln and all
their
allies because is a huge responsibility
the common person has been expecting a
lot from them because the ptis uh
supporter
their stomach was full their bank
accounts was full their petrol tax is
full so they has nothing to do with the
common person common person's challenges
in pakistan is very different and for
that you have to be a person democratic
person who understand the constitution
all right let's say
he's part of harry potter
to respond so we have a new prime
minister now in place uh the the
protests i mean i don't know what you
feel they're going to achieve but isn't
it in the benefit of all pakistanis to
move forward now and address this urgent
issue that is tackling and propping up
the economy what would you hope the new
prime minister will prioritize
i think the the new prime minister has
his hands full a
he's come in on an international
conspiracy mandate which you said that
we haven't proven i just want to clarify
that that's completely incorrect okay
tell us how
this is called
the
notes
the national security council was called
it has all three chiefs the navy
the army and the air force chiefs in
there the opposition leaders at the time
who are now in power were all invited to
that council
to the national security council they
all refused to come
all three serving armed chiefs signed
off that they feel that there was a
intervention and that the words and the
notes used
in the meeting held in washington were
unacceptable and hence the foreign
office has written back the dimash back
to them of
talking about a regime change and not
willing to work
with imran khan and but
if
if the government is removed then all of
pakistan's
faults would be
omitted so this is this is something
where all three chiefs have signed off
to and has gone to the supreme court it
was given to the national
national speaker
the because it's a confidential letter
there are certain rules and requirements
that need to go about but they didn't
want to see it they wanted to make sure
they avoided it i'm glad they're in
power now and that they can go through
it and if they can find a way of making
it public it should be made public so so
to say that its fault is absolutely
wrong because it's gone through the
highest level of security council with
everybody sitting there and i repeat the
opposition who is speaking now refused
to turn up for that meeting the
thousands and millions of people you see
on the roads not only in pakistan but
probably every single country across
including including qatar including uae
are people who are not accepting them
when we talk about a democratic this is
a democratic movement no it's not this
is an alliance of people who are either
on bail
or have run or their brothers are run
away as convicted criminals sitting in
london his brother's now the prime
minister who is on on bail himself at
the moment the leader of
pakistan's people's party ppp himself is
internationally known as a criminal so
do understand what this alliance is it's
not democratic it's an alliance okay
maria let's put that to you i mean these
these are alliances have been
historically and loggerheads it has to
be said with competing interests how are
they going to stay united until
elections respond to what we've just
heard from mr zofikar bakari
of course when pdm's movement started in
back in september 2020 that was a
sign charter which said about clearly
that we will enforce and implement
constitution we will make parliament
status autonomous we will we believe in
freedom of speech expression and
assembly we believe in the democratic
governments we believe in the
sovereignty of provisional governments
we will protect the rights of peoples of
pakistan we will protect the foreign
policy economic policy and we will
respect our
armed forces
as well so in this government we saw
they made every institutional institute
so controversial that this is the
biggest challenge which we see as a
political worker that in coming days we
have to start it from zero you know in
three and a half years of time when they
were there all they did is accusing
their opposition now the opposition who
has taken over and of course people are
very happy people
they can't see it but we see whoever
understands pakistan and the governments
who have
presented people previously they know
they believe in them and i'm sure in
coming days after 10 days or 15 days if
you call somebody from pakistan people's
party tmln and pti you will see the
clear picture of pakistan that how
pakistan has been growing and yesterday
we saw a stock index uh position where
the
value of rupees has gone up okay and you
know
we need to respect that in a one day
time there's so many things has been
happening so is the baby government is
it just
keeping you away for for some time now
let me bring you back into the
conversation we've heard from uh mr
zulfikar bukhari and imran khan's party
in general that the u.s was behind this
effort to push him out uh even even if
his party had good relations with
washington at some point how much damage
has that done you think to relations
with the u.s and how difficult will it
be for the new prime minister to mend
size
well uh
if if you ask me to be fair that some
damage might have been done because if
you are
getting into the uh domestic politics
the international players and uh i must
say that this is a very very dangerous
line that the pti government has has
towed upon it and will be very difficult
not only for this government but maybe
next time in the next election if pta
wins the election and they get back into
the government in pakistan after 2023
elections or whenever the elections
future elections are held it will be a
very difficult situation for them to
handle
as far as the allegations on the
politicians are concerned let me say
that
almost everybody has cases against them
even the prime minister imran khan
ex-prime minister imran khan had some
cases against him so is the case with
the uh other uh
leadership in the country so if i'm not
getting into the blame game here the
point is the pakistani situation is a
very very precarious situation as i've
been pointed out there are a foreign
exchange problem there is an inflation
problem the common man particularly hit
by the covet and overall the economic
meltdown in pakistan has literally
broken their back so it's time to get
together it's time to get some sort of
stability into the things it's time to
get out of these hysterical things it's
time to get together and see the things
how they are for the betterment of the
people i i must say that the pta has all
the right to come onto the street and if
they are peaceful and if they are
saying that whatever they want to say
and there is freedom of expression on
them they must have all the right to say
but the government has come out of the
opposition now and now it is their
responsibility to do what they have to
do put the economic house in the order
some of the indications that my
colleague has pointed out is just one
day i'm not too easy to jump on to those
early conclusions because there it's
very early days but there is a very
difficult way to go ahead uh this
situation in pakistani economics wi-fi
not say that's crisis-like but it is
pretty precarious at the moment the
foreign exchange rate is is very very
alarming let me say that some of the
policies adopted by the previous
government they were literally not
advisable hence they changed their three
frame finance minister within a frame of
not more than four years so something
has been done which was not advisable at
that point in time hence these these
these economic conditions got out of the
hand and everybody accepted the uh
leadership in punjab even now they are
accepting when they nominate each other
for the premiership of punjab so
everybody knew that the leadership in
punjab was not delivering and i agree
with this that punjab is more than 60 of
pakistan in terms of population so if
you are not delivering in punjab you are
not delivering in pakistan some soul
searching should also go into the
previous government
they may claim that they have been not
dealt with an even hand but they must
look into the thing that they come back
into power they should not repeat those
mistakes which they have been doing for
the last four years or so all right
we'll leave it there unfortunately we've
run out of time i wish we had more time
because there's quite a lot to discuss
still thank you so much for joining us
zulfi kabukari maria igba tavana and
zubair iqbal thank you and thank you for
watching you can watch this program
again anytime by visiting our website at
aljazeera.com for further discussion go
to our facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
fully [ __ ] and the whole team here
in doha thanks for watching bye for now
[Music]
you